in ukraine there are battles raging on
many fronts as ukrainian civilians and
their military defend ukraine on the
ground there's a growing cyber army of
hackers committed to defending ukraine
and attacking russia in these cyber
attacks waves of fishing emails hit
ukraine's military personnel allegedly
originating with a bella russian hacking
crew
distributed denial of service or ddos
attacks which flood websites with
traffic until they collapse continue to
inundate government targets
wiping malware spreads across the nation
capable of destroying a computer's
memory in seconds on saturday mikhailo
fedorov vice prime minister of ukraine
announced the formation of an i.t army
it amassed more than 120 000 members in
a single day
it has given out lists of targets
including websites of the russian
government and businesses on monday the
it army claimed it was behind the
takedown of the moscow exchange and
sebero bank russia's largest lender the
group has also been called to counter
russian misinformation on youtube and
across the web
even tesla ceo elon musk jumped into the
fray delivering terminals to connect to
starlink a satellite-based internet
service operated by spacex on monday the
terminals are meant to maintain internet
connectivity in ukraine which would help
the it army
last thursday during the early days of
the fighting igor auschev the founder of
numerous cybersecurity companies in
ukraine said he'd recruited a group of
guerrilla hackers inside and outside
ukrainian borders together they'll be
playing offense and defense trying to
protect resources and break into russian
systems
aushaf told forbes he has a direct line
to government defense officials in the
capital kiev who can tell him what needs
protecting and what needs targeting
ukrainian officials declined to comment
to forbes and to reuters which first
reported auschev's project the russian
side has their own hackers as well
earlier in february russia successfully
took down government military websites
as well as the websites of bank private
bank in osha bank on friday russian
hacker group conti best known for
ransomware attacks on the world health
organization pledged to help russia
counter cyber attacks from the west by
monday the group itself had been hacked
and had their information leaked online
while it pales in comparison to the
fighting on the ground the cyber front
could prove to be pivotal in the
conflict
[Music]
you